you know because normally what I do
every day is I grab like the big story
and I'm like here's the thing that
happened here's what it means here's
what's going on here's some other stuff
about it and like the other day I was
talking about oh Biden scandal the
emails apparently Hunter Biden emails
from his laptop suggests he had access
to classified information and it seems
like in emails they were directly
getting information straight from the
White House so that's a big Scandal
today there was more information on it
that they had rated the Penn Biden
Center or whatever and so there's like
the FBI who were doing raids on the
bidens for a while now before the
midterms and they weren't telling us and
then I was just like thinking about uh
Chuck Todd Jim Jordan goes on uh goes on
Meet the Press and he says you know
Chuck Todd's like but Trump had
classified documents and he's like Trump
is the president and they were guarded
by the Secret Service and they were
locked up and Biden had him sitting in
his garage and then just for tribal
reasons Chuck Todd says no no like you
can't see it you know it's a it's a
conspiracy and it's just like